everybody was going on welcome to
another PI game with PI OpenGL and
obviously Python tutorial video in this
video what we talk about is how we can
take our block generations and turn them
even into an even better infinite
possibilites sort of idea so right now
we have a working version of infinite
block creation so this will just
continue happening but we always have a
couple of problems that we can notice
right away and some one of the major
problems is blocks just kind of appear
out of nowhere and so that's no good
also we can avoid all blocks by simply
scrolling up like this and then we not
don't worry so we need kind of handling
to handle both of these events so let's
go and get started so the first thing
that I'd like to us to do is let's go
ahead and modify the new or basically
set vertices function here and you'll
see that we have max distance min
distance and now we are going to add two
more parameters the first one whoops the
first one will be a camera underscore X
and we'll set that default to zero and
then we're going to have camera
underscore Y and again we'll set that to
a default of 0 and this will be will be
passing through where are we in the 3d
environment then we can make boxes
basically that correspond to where we
are next we see first of all let's go
ahead and come down here and well right
away we want to we basically flip camera
x and y so camera underscore x equals
negative 1 times the int of camera X and
then we have camera underscore y equals
negative 1 times the int of camera
underscore Y so we're just flipping
those around now
now like what I was saying before you
need to have enough movement on either
side of the
camera erna possibility for cubes on
either side of the camera
up-down left-right to account for the
person literally just pressing and
holding their arrow key just constantly
moving over to the side to avoid cubes
so we need to kind of account for this
so now we're going to do is x-value
change and we're going to say x-value
change equals camera um well I it's a
random dot R and range of camera
underscore X - 75 - camera underscore X
+ 75 so where is the X and then 75 units
on either either side so now we'll take
this let's just copy-paste and instead
of camera X that's camera Y and that's
good enough um z change we don't need to
change anything there so now we've
basically we've got set vertices that is
is done okay so now what we want to do
is we're going to come down into our
main loop here and we want to do a few
things first of all we've been
continuing to like kind of place
ourselves a little randomly here and um
to an extent I guess that doesn't really
matter but let's just for simplicity's
sake go ahead and just replace that with
zero zero we were doing that whenever we
were looping the main the main loop you
know 10 times and having us being like a
random location so the cube looked like
it looked like it was coming randomly so
uh so we've done that the next thing
that we're going to go ahead and do is
you've got X move Y move and now let's
go ahead and do it corrects we'll say
equals zero and cur underscore Y we'll
say equals zero then what we'll go ahead
and do is we'll come down here where do
we have the x and y move so we've got GL
translate and all that and the other
thing that we want to do is we're going
to
Aker underscore X plus equals x move and
then cur underscore y plus equals y move
so we'll modify corrects and curve y
which is the current location
subsequently whenever we go to define
here this cube Dyck set vertices we've
got new max int camera Z and really
we don't we don't want the camera um
let's see
I think what we'll do is first of all
the new max so the new maximum is the
new like how far out can we go
we'll do basically camera Z - max
distance times - so basically added this
right so now the new max is basically
that where are we now - you know or
moving out the max distance times - so
that's the maximum distance for a new
cube and now we have we already know
what new max is because that's what we
just said right we've just redefined
what new max is and then the minimum
distance right so the closest to the
camera possible is actually going to be
camera Z - max distance and so the
reason why we're doing that is because
when we were saying like you know the
cube can be anywhere between the cameras
view and the max distance was cubes
we're just popping up in our face and we
can't have that
so now cubes will not pop up in our face
they will all pop past just past the
clipping plane or it well just pass the
clipping paint - you know basically -
clipping planes away so there's that and
then now finally we have to pass the
cameras x and y-coordinates so we'll
just say cur underscore X comma cur
underscore Y and that should basically
be basically be it the other thing I
wouldn't mind having us do right now is
let's just go ahead and comment out
pygame duck time dot wait there's really
no reason to have that and basically
because we're pretty much like going to
be like right on the line of heavy
processing so I just don't think what
we'll need a timer there so anyways
let's go ahead and save and run it and
see see what we come up with here
hopefully no no major errors yet so as
you can see cubes are kind of spawning
one major problem that we have at the
moment well first of all we don't have
any
cubes yet there we go beginning to
wonder if we would get new cubes so
we've got some new cubes coming so let
me move this over a little bit here but
we can see they kind of seem to be
coming in groups which kind of makes
sense because they're all being made
past the clipping plane and then once
there's no more we kind of have some
more now there's a couple things that we
could do like we could cut we could go
up sorry I have this running on a
different monitor and then ignored it so
let's go ahead and close out of this
first of all past a cube can go away we
don't need to be printing that out
anymore and I'm going to get rid of
delete list and then basically all that
since we don't need it
um right I was going to add more cubes
so for X and range let's try a 75 see if
we can do that without lag it's still a
little laggy for me part of the problem
is just the distance that these are
traveling at any one time let me speed
up the distance so
it's moving at 0.5 let's go ahead and
move it let's go move in twos yeah it's
still pretty still pretty jittery for me
and but let's go ahead and test a couple
of things so let's first of all let's
move oh wow the player move needs to be
a lot quicker I suppose since we're you
know trying to tweak things this really
just brings up the point that we need to
have some more constants here so up here
is where we're going to say we're going
to go ahead and say game underscore
speed will say that's two so game speed
will be basically down here where is it
where we move so GL translate right X
move Y move replace two with game speeds
so whatever we set game speed to will be
the speed of the game and then we'll say
a direct Direction speed we'll say
that's a two as well so then we can take
Direction speed copy that and then
basically we can come down here where
you have X move Y moves a direction
speed and then Direction speed and this
will be negative one times direction
speed and again Direction speed negative
one times that and then Direction speed
and so now we can modify these these
values a little easier and then we'll
make that 50 so 50 cubes game speeds 2
Direction speed is 2 let's run it all
right not bad on my computer so we'll
stick with that and then now let's go
ahead and try to move up okay so we're
just constantly moving up here and we're
still you know we don't have as many
cubes as we would like
necessarily and we're actually being
able to avoid basically all cubes but
the concept of infinity is clearly
working the question is are we still
going to have people able to cheat just
by doing this like will they ever run
into a cube so in theory we might need
to generate the cubes further or we can
make the game go a little faster but
something would have to give
okay so anyways that's going to conclude
this video so we've kind of covered a
lot of things but you know the movement
where are we generating new cubes kind
of off the screen so we can keep the
player moving they can basically go
infinitely in any direction and there
will still always be cubes coming their
way
so that's that if you guys have any
questions or comments on this video feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time